Alice Through the Looking Glass sequel
everyone wanted because everyone loved
Alice in Wonderland directed by Tim
Burton actually no it was very
polarizing critics and audiences both
pretty much felt the same way for once
fine I guess is Johnny Depp is face
paint but the one thing that's
undeniable about Alice in Wonderland
that came out in 2010 is that it made a
crap ton of money it made over 1 billion
dollars worldwide that's a lot of money
I'm actually surprised it took six years
to make this movie with a gross like
that it seems like by now
there'd be a movie every single year for
Alice in Wonderland was spin-off sequels
involving the Cheshire Cat nevertheless
this movie is once again about Alice she
goes through a mirror back to Wonderland
and learns that the Mad Hatter is very
sad because he remembered suddenly that
he had a family once and they died I
guess and that really makes him sad so
to make the Mad Hatter happy again she
goes back in time using the chronosphere
which belongs to time himself played by
Sacha Baron Cohen while at the same time
realizing who she is in the real world
while trying to maintain her career as a
sea boat captain in the actual world I
mean so many plots and this movie just
couldn't balance it I wanted to go into
this film and be swept away into a world
where wonderment exists where aw is
something so important and where one
man's happiness creates an entire
deathtrap that could literally collapse
the entire world I wanted to accept that
but the movie just had such a hard time
balancing all the stories and really
justifying this sequels existence as I
already said the first film wasn't
really that well-received it just made a
lot of money Tim Burton didn't even
return to direct this movie it's
directed by James Bobin who directed the
most recent Muppets movie the first one
I thought being very good most recent
most wanted so much with this film there
isn't much style or flair to the
direction it's very flat everything
looks as if it's shot on a green screen
room and a lot of the CG animation looks
like animation it feels as if some real
people are walking around fake
artificial environments and every once
in a while there might be a handrail or
a door for them to knock on or something
that's actually tangible in
existence that they can interact with
while going like this at a ton of CGI
elements and that can sometimes work in
a movie really well but it just doesn't
work here as I said this director
previously worked on the Muppet movies
in which humans interacted with things
that weren't real but they were real
things puppets Kermit Miss Piggy these
are things that people can look at and
have an emotional attachment to in this
film he's made another film in which
actors are interacting with artificial
things but there's nothing there for
them to really interact with and that
really shows in this film this is the
perfect example of how important it is
to have a filmmaker who understands how
to communicate the needed emotions for
an actor to convey in a scene to make it
all feel real and cohesive now I'm not
going to trash the director of this
movie because why would I do that he
made a film and films are really hard to
make but it is definitely something I
noticed as I watched this movie that
there just wasn't that real emotion that
felt as if it was consistent throughout
each scene interacting with these fake
elements also at this point do we really
need to know how everyone became who
they are in a movie that was successful
does there always have to be a prequel
to tell its story do we have to know why
the Mad Hatter went mad no do we have to
know why the Evil Queen is just so damn
evil no do we have to know what Darth
Vader didn't he was a kid no we don't
sorry that's another review the movie
has a good message overall the
importance of family the importance of
being yourself the importance of not
accepting what the world tells you you
should be and making your own path these
are all good messages it's just that the
movie surrounding it has such a hard
time honing it into a cohesive story and
it becomes a mess of CGI bad acting
combined with that CGI and a total
cluster bomb of stories that just don't
mix I'm going to give Alice Through the
Looking Glass
a d-plus so guys I can't even tell you
how many times over the past seven years
I've been asked where do you get all
that stuff in your background where do
you get these cool items I'm going to
start telling you every once in a while
starting with this guy right here that
is Wolverine from the film The Wolverine
and oh my gosh it is beautiful it's a
hot toy I have wanted a hot toy for a
very long time made by Sideshow
Collectibles and I bought that at big
bad toy store which is in my opinion the
best online toy store flat-out the
amount of things they have of that store
is mind-boggling a ton of the banpresto
Dragonball Z items that I own are
available at the big bad toy store and
that's why I love that store I like
supporting businesses that I genuinely
love and use myself and these guys are
worth it I really really suggest
checking out that store I have a special
link in the description below you guys
can go and look at all of the products
they have because they have extremely
competitive prices and I love that story
my gosh that that Logan you can take
that tank top off I know what I'm doing
tonight
mmm you guys are the best thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes